de poner las armas y eliminar el veneno
del odio Ese es el mensaje que el Papa
Francisco dejó en su último familia en
Sudán del sur donde este domingo
concluyó su misión en el país más joven
del mundo marcado por el conflicto y la
división el líder de la Iglesia Católica
se dirigió alrededor de 70.000 personas
desde el mausoleo del héroe de la
liberación John Arango
queridos hermanos y hermanas vuelvo a
Roma con ustedes aún más cerca de mi
corazón
portándome ancura
lo repito siete en nuestro cobre Déjenme
repetir ustedes están en mi corazón
están en nuestros corazones están en los
corazones de los cristianos en todo el
mundo Nunca pierdan la esperanza y no
pierdan ninguna oportunidad de construir
la paz que la esperanza y la paz habiten
entre ustedes que la esperanza y la paz
moren en Sudán del sur la esperanza y la
Apache ni Moreno y sus Sudán en la misa
el papa estuvo acompañado por Jean
greens y Justin referentes de la iglesia
de Escocia y de la comunión anglicana
mundial respectivamente congregaciones
importantes en Sudán del sur También
estuvo presente el arzobispo de shuba
quien se dirigió a la multitud
[Música]
compartimos su paternal preocupación por
el restablecimiento de la paz en nuestro
país la guerra trajo consigo la
destrucción indiscriminada de bienes
humanas y la destrucción de bienes como
viviendas y ganado
durante su estadía en Sudán del sur El
Papa llamó a abandonar el tribalismo las
irregularidades financieras y la
corrupción Política Francisco cerró su
histórica misión la primera vez que
acuden los líderes de las tradiciones
católicas anglicana y reformada en una
visita conjunta al extra